oh mein gott freundlich habe den
weltrekord schaut euch das an sie
richtig ich bin
hallo mein name ist luca und draußen ist
es ganz sehr stark am regnen weil ich
mama fans auch in china hat man nicht
ich habe einfach mal nach agrio biggest
sl gegoogelt da habe ich bilder gefunden
wie beispielsweise das hier oder das
hier oder auch das hier einfach so auf
reinem interesse gefragt was denn der ak
rio weltrekord
da habe ich dann bilder gefunden wie
beispielsweise das hier dieses hier oder
auch dieses bild hier da ich so ein
super spieler bin hab ich mir gedacht
ich nehme mal ziel neuen weltrekord
aufzustellen da der name natürlich immer
recht klein gewählt werden muss konnte
ich nur ich will welt nehmen die leute
wissen trotzdem was ich meine oh mein
gott
ich dachte ich kann den essen konnte ich
dann doch nicht
freunde marielle talk ist halt echt übel
scassa im rechnen und ich sehe halt in
der tonspur sogar dass man das mit krieg
das tut mir leid mit dem regen freuen
ich hab support von der regierung angela
merkel ist auf meiner seite
ich weiß nicht wer von uns beiden die
größere miss gestalt gerade ist die
tatsächlich wird als die 8 japan dann
gelangen
die leute diesen halt einfach dass ich
eine mission haben dass ich versuche
wirklich hier gerade geschichte die
ordner in frankreich
nein falls ihr euch fragt luca hast du
denn irgendwas vorzuweisen warst du
überhaupt schon mal hast du überhaupt
chicago gespielt ich verlinke euch mal
hier ein video wo ich der erste platz in
kario wurde schaut euch das an lasten
leid da klickt auf die werbung kauft bei
merchandise und dann ab ins bett
ja dass angie hier ich bin auf dem
reiterhof
putin kommen die leute hier wissen halt
einfach dass ich ein sehr erfahrener und
sehr guter spieler bin und drehen
deshalb die ein oder andere runde aber
es macht keinen sinn
rumänien kampf wenig essen ich weiß der
ak rio ist schon so ein bisschen weg
aber ich habe halt einfach dieses ziel
heute einen weltrekord zu knacken
und viele hatten sich tatsächlich mal
wieder gar io von mir erfahren einem
tollen das habe ich hier grad gedrückt
wenn leute das er wegnehmen und wissen
dass es deutsches könnte man denken ich
will welt und ich bin ein hitler
anhänger
aber nein die wissen was ich meine hallo
weltrekord von youtube zuschauer das ist
nicht wahr
jetzt hänge ich hier mit zwei anderen
rum die genauso groß sind wie ich und
jeder hat jetzt angst vor uns wir sind
keine clique da ist ein lahmer
eigentlich mag ich lammers aber ich
glaub ich muss dich leider jetzt essen
oder das ist wieder eine riskante luca
aktion am eingetroffen
ich sollte lieber sicher spiel lama
bleibt doch einfach hier hinter mir ich
will jedoch recht nichts böses ich werde
sogar das lama in der video beschreibung
verlinken wenn es mir beim weltrekord
hilfen wird lama japan einen kleinen
schritt zurück japan kom kom kom kom
das ist nicht wahr
japan passiert nichts
das spiel ist komplett kks putin weiß
ich gar nicht putin essen
fakt ist er trete man hier passiert
nichts ich bin nicht mal in den top ten
wisst ihr was wenn man den weltrekord
will muss man einfach mal aufs klo gehen
immer noch nicht in den köpfen und
grafiker noch immer nicht in den top ten
was soll denn da hat für einen
weltrekord muss man einfach hin und
wieder zeit mitbringen
und wie schon mehrmals gesagt muss man
das ein oder andere mal auch ein mit dem
risiko eingehen
ich bin auf dem siebten platz das ist
bei jay immer noch mein erstes spiel mit
dem namen oder das liegt an meinem neuen
merchandise den ihr auf luca - shop.de
kaufen
ich bin grad lokal im schnitt je sie das
video zwar gerade am zweiten dezember
irgendwann nachmittags ich schneide das
video allerdings gerade einen tag vorher
also am ersten dezember mitten in der
nacht weil ich den zweiten mann den
ganzen tag leider unterwegs sein werde
und zwar packe ich jetzt mal eben diesen
einschub ein weil ich ja gerade in der
szene über diesen merchandising
gesprochen habe das muss ich euch
allerdings ganz kurz was sagen ich
versuche mich sehr sehr schnell zu
fassen und zwar ging der shop gestern um
16 uhr online allerdings war nach einer
stunde nahezu alles ausverkauft und um
19 uhr waren schon insgesamt über 1000
sachen bestellt und es war viel zu krank
und wir hätten alle nicht mit so einem
krassen ansturm von euch gerechnet wir
haben halt nur ein paar sachen bisher
auf lager gepackt weil ich so gedacht
hatte ja vielleicht gestellt ein paar
leute was vielleicht feiern für leute
das sei nicht vielleicht denken einige
dass es zu simpel ist allerdings wurden
so fucking viele sachen bestellt und
dafür wollte mich einfach entschuldigen
dass da jetzt viele noch nichts
bestellen konnten ich glaube der
schwarze hut des ausverkauft der große
ausverkauf der sonova smileys ausverkauf
andere sachen gibts noch in bestimmten
größen wie nis und turnbeutel sind auch
fast nahezu gar nicht mehr da wir haben
neue sachen bestellt die kommt
allerdings erst so in zwei wochen an
das ist halt das problem wir arbeiten
derzeit daran dass wir eventuell sogar
wenn ihr das video sieht oder morgen
oder übermorgen so bei den sachen die
eigentlich ausverkauft sind button drin
haben wir dann steht vorbestellen das
heißt dann die sachen bekommt ihr dann
quasi in zwei wochen das heißt dann
irgendwie am 16 17 18 dezember definitiv
vor weihnachten und vielleicht mit
autogramm weil ich mir gedacht habe ja
so klein und so ein bisschen als
entschuldigung dafür dass der shop hat
wirklich direkt aus verkaufen war hab
ich euch noch mal irgendwie 700 ca
signiert dazu dass nummer 700
bestellungen sticker bekommen es tut mir
einfach leid ist alles verkauft ich bin
einfach mega überwältigt und wollte mich
dafür bedanken dass ihr so viel da
gekauft habt nur jetzt sage ich erst mal
bitte abwarten wenn ihr noch was vor
weihnachten haben wollt dann checkt
einfach mal täglich den luca shop aus ob
da wieder was da sein wird ob ihr was
bestellen könnt
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem video super
ich bin sicher ich will trotzdem einfach
nur den weltrekord dass videos in der
raw datei gerade mal wieder zehn jahre
lang und ich muss das gleich wieder vier
stunden lang zusammen schneiden alles
klar alles klar auch das ist doch nicht
war als ob ich jetzt auch noch gleich
groß bin
nein
da will ich jetzt auch nicht mehr auch
jetzt noch in rumänien und die toll seid
ihr
wow ich bin gott freundlich hat den
weltrekord
schaut euch das an wie riesig ich bin ja
nachdem ich jetzt diesen weltrekord
erreicht habe wollte ich euch nur sagen
danke
im vollem namen ich denke meiner familie
also euch dreien wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen und wir sehen uns
dann
wir sehen uns